entrenamiento con el grupo completo en
la víspera de esa gran final contra la
albiceleste tanto Rafael bagán como
ibrahimacona como kingsley koman están
de regreso después de haberse visto
afectados por ese cuadro viral también
volvieron Teo Hernández y estos dos
últimos afectados por molestias físicas
en rueda de prensa El seleccionador
habló acerca de ese virus que impidió
por ejemplo que Adrián mexicano y el
propio command estuvieran disponibles
para ese duelo de semifinales contra
Marruecos afirmó el entrenador francés
que tienen que mantener la calma que
sería mejor obviamente Si no existiera
ese cuadro pero que han tratado de
manejarlo de la mejor manera posible
Francia que se mide este domingo contra
Argentina en su cuarta final de mundial
en 24 años el mejor registro en los
últimos años un duelo que se ha centrado
por la prensa en esos duelos
individuales de esto se quiso desmarcar
El capitán
el guardameta que afirmó que es un duelo
mucho más importante como para centrarse
en solamente un jugador